thank you for inviting me to this it was
uh
great fun to be in i've never been in
chicago before so
it's quite an experience to be here it's
quite unusual to find it
colder indoors than outdoors because in
stockholm it's the other way around
um so when i was invited to give this
talk i
what happens when people invite me to
give talks i usually say no and
and then i say maybe and
and then i write a sort of title that i
think looks okay and i
wrote a title and said i'd accepted this
and i tweeted this title
and could you turn the volume up a tiny
bit more please um
so i tweeted this title systems that run
forever self-heal and scale and
immediately
um somebody tweeted back well that's
impossible you know you can't
i can't i mean forever is actually quite
a long time so so i'm not going to
not going to make systems that run
forever they just run for a few years or
you know a few hundred years or
something like that but not forever
because
the earth's not going to be here forever
anyway so um
uh self-heal that's pretty obvious um if
they're gonna run
for a very long time they're going to
get bugs in them so they're going to
crash and we need to fix them as they're
going along and we want to scale them up
to
sort of planetary wise things so that's
that's the theme of this talk
and what i want to do is kind of
set the scene for that because i've been
working with systems like that for
quite a long time and
some parts of making systems like that
is pretty difficult and other parts are
pretty easy
and so i want to kind of just give you
some kind of feeling for the bits which
i think are difficult in the bits that i
think are easy and how you go about
doing that and what sailing got to do
with all of this
um so the plan for this talk is i just
sort of
introduced the problem domain it's this
highly concurrent highly
connected world um just talk about some
algorithms and architectures
and and then and then i just go into
what i call six rules for making systems
i'm kind of not so intro i mean this
might sound funny coming from me i'm not
really so interested in programming
language i'm interested in solving
problems airlines
one of those languages that was
developed
to solve a specific problem it turns out
to be very good at solving that problem
surprisingly it's also good at solving
other problems but that's not
by design that's more by accident
and i'll talk about the reasons for that
given that you've got those six rules
you could actually implement them in any
any language you like
uh if you constructed the language
to have certain properties um you can
bolt these properties on top of other
language they weren't explicitly
constructed in that way so you'll get
the
you get the sort of feeling for it but
not not the not the behavior that you
get in early i'll show you how they're
programmed in airline
right so so what's the problem domain
well
um i want you to think about
somehow we've got to go from this this
is that that's a sequential program
that's that's all sequential programming
languages look like that to me
there's just one sort of thing and
you've got to do everything in it
right that's all sequential programming
and here's airline you see
so it doesn't look like that it's a
completely different
world you see you're not you're not
talking about one process
or one computation that's going to do
everything you're talking about
thousands possibly millions of
computations
that are going to do things and
they're all isolated they're all doing
their little things and they're all
talking to each other so
we have to understand this sort of world
i don't want to understand that other
world
that other world is is a very strange
world i mean
if you're programming things in the real
world um they're parallel i mean the
real world is proud of hundreds of
people in this room
it would be extraordinarily difficult to
try and describe that in a single pro i
mean how would i describe it you're
thinking that and then i
sort of interleave and then you're
thinking this and then you're thinking
that and i go around you all and then we
get back to you
and how would you program that i
couldn't program that but i could
program it as
you know 300 parallel processes i always
like to think of failing processes like
little people
because we've we've all got private
memory
and we all communicate by message
passing i've got my memory you've got
your memory and i
speak to you and the words go and this
message passing channel is imperfect you
you might not be listening when i speak
or
or you know a jet might go by and
obscure the noise you don't hear it so
that's really how
my little processes work they've each
got private memory they just send
messages to each other
we don't know if the messages get there
or not if you want to know if a message
got there you've got to send a message
back
then you'll know it got there so we're
not really making any
big assumptions about how the world
behaves and this actually how
i used to be a physicist this is how a
physicist would would view the world you
know
there's no such thing as similar nuity
we don't know
what's happening now we know how it was
at the time it takes the ray of light to
go from a to b you know i
i don't see you now i see how you were
a micro or a pico second earlier because
of the time it takes life to get from
from me to you it's the same with
software when we send messages to each
other we don't actually know how they
are now
we know how they were in the past and we
have to live with that
we can't change the laws of physics we
have to live with that
so so this world has got lots and lots
of computers
um lots is sort of rather vague term but
it could be anything from you know
i wouldn't call two lots but it's
certainly more than one it
probably lot starts at about 10 and goes
up to a few tens of thousands possibly
millions of computers we
don't actually know how to program
millions of computers in early
at the moment because we haven't got
millions of computers but there are
research projects who are
figuring out how to do that actually the
million core cpu sort of projects are
sort of going on to the research horizon
now of course if you've got this world
with lots of lots of
computers they're all executing things
in parallel and it's distributed
uh it's concurrent because they're all
running at the same time
and faults are going to happen
and so it's not a question of saying
well let's use
type systems or let's use something so
that no faults can occur
it's more the case that faults are going
to occur and then you're going to have
to detect them
and do something about it you're going
to have to worry about consistency
or rather the lack of consistency i mean
if you've got thousands of computers
it's just kind of unrealistic to think
you can put it into a consistent state
so you're going to have to live with
inconsistency and
if you want it to run forever you're
going to have to change the code in it
as it's executing i mean
you just cannot there's no such thing as
an atomic upgrade stop
it change the code restart it if it
is every single computer on the planet
it's just not going to work so
you're going to have to have this notion
of things sort of partially upgrading
themselves and an upgrade to take
time and of living with different
versions at the same time
um so one of the things that
actually the primary thing that erlang
was designed
to do was was to do fault tolerant
computations so
let's let's just think about that for a
moment so um
there's this kind of world
this this is really two ways to design
things you can either sort of start with
small things
and scale them up or you could start
with big things and scale them down and
see if you can get it the same
way so suppose you're building a system
and
you want it to be said you want to build
a system for like 10 000 people
to use simultaneously one way of doing
it would be to start with the system
design it for
10 people and test it like that and
scale it up to 10 000
the the other way would be to design it
for like 100 million people
i mean do the design for that and then
scale it down to ten thousands and
you you might not get at the same
architecture you might get a completely
different architecture in fact you would
get a different architecture
and i think in general it's really bad
idea to start
at a design that works for 10 or 100
things
and scale it up it's better to start
with an architecture that you know will
work for
a few trillion things and scale it down
it will actually be less efficient
when you've got your 10 000 than one you
scaled up but you'll know that you'll be
able to scale it up later so
it's good so rather than ask how do we
get to five nines i'd really like
let let's make it more interesting let's
let's start at
you know nine thousand nine hundred
ninety nine nines reliability scale it
down
okay so
so let's make a system that's got 9999
reliability well that's easy well it's
not quite easy
there's a tricky bit right so well
that's really easy because
if things are independent these are just
probabilities if the probability that
one thing fails is ten to the minus
three
just get three thousand three hundred
and thirty three independent machines
around them all in parallel
and uh the probability they all fail at
the same time is ten to the
minus nine nine nine nine so you've got
your four or nine oh that's not four
nines reliabilities
9999 live if that's pretty easy
okay so the difficult bit is making them
independent
right so um oh and
does this work yeah i've just put in a
few slides to show that well we believe
this sort of technology works this is um
a very this is this is what
i do right when i'm not here i work for
erickson
and this thing here
is a connection but this stuff down here
this this is your 4g
lte wideband cdma 3g out here
and this stiff stuff over there ip
network that's internet
right and we put a bot so so let me
the software abstraction of that is this
okay
[Laughter]
well software people do bubbles and
arrows and things you see so this is
millions of smartphones and that's
erlang
and that's the internet
and that box in the middle that connects
smartphones to internet now it actually
connects about half the smartphone
traffic in the world
right so if you've got a smartphone and
if you're using data traffic
then there's about a 50 chance you're
going through an airline thing but
if you're if the base stations are
programmed sorry
if you've purchased your base stations
from ericsson okay if you've
purchased them from our competitors then
they won't be an airline they'll be in c
or something like that um so it's about
half the world smartphone traffic is
going through these things
and we built a thing here this is this
is erickson i've just
sort of taken some stuff um this is a
that's the you know i showed you the
first picture that was the architect
second one's a software abstraction this
is the sales abstraction which you've
showed to customers
that thing is a box it's a big sort of
box
um and uh it's not really very exciting
actually
um but it's one of those boxes
right we don't sell many of them
actually has got the goals are six nines
reliability and uh
18 million um simultaneous connected
subscribers
and uh low power consumption purpose
that's all programmed in erlang
and uh works quite nicely thank you very
much
so this is pretty similar to um
internet high availability uh there
you want sort of thousands to millions
of users kind of soft real time
upgrade them as they go along
you don't really stop these systems i
mean
google doesn't sort of go offline to do
code upgrade at midnight
um it's you know there isn't really a
midnight
because when it's midnight here it's not
midnight in
sweden and so on so so there's not
really a midnight when you perhaps say
stop it at midnight in america and
change all the code and
restart it and that's what the banks do
they they turn them off at four o'clock
in the morning and leave them off it
takes about an hour or something and
then they come back online again and
well we don't do that in telephony we
google don't do it
we want to make these things very
scalable right
so i i was kind of looking for some
distributed programming is in a sense
hard it's also difficult
it's also easy but i i searched on the
internet a little bit i was just
searching for
why distributed programming is hard i
found this blog
and i sort of thought that's right i
don't know who this guy is but he'd
written a blog he put down five reasons
why
um distributed programming was was uh
was hard so i wrote them down here i
thought yeah i agree with that it's
difficult
it's difficulty in identifying and
dealing with failures
when he wrote his blog i disagree with
that actually i think i think that bit's
quite easy
i'll tell you why um point two achieving
consistency in data across
processes is difficult and i'm going to
go into that in a little bit of
a little bit of detail just to give you
some kind of feeling for why i think
it's difficult
uh these big systems say they are not
homogeneous that we we don't
build systems in one language even if
i'd like you to build the whole system
and you're not going to do it with
several different languages and try and
connect them together and testing them
um is pretty difficult because you can't
they're not kind of reproducible you
can't
put them in the same state every time
and often
um it's it's not they're not
these big distributed systems require an
awful lot of special purpose hardware
and kit
i mean in order to test some of the
software we were writing you you had to
book a test facility
and you could get like two days in three
weeks
and that wasn't enough you you you know
you
go into a room half this size full of
equipment and say okay here's your test
facility
and you have no clue what to do so you
need a whole lot of little
chaps who run around and you tell them
what you want and you've got to rig it
and and that's what actually makes tests
you know continuous development
continues
to you know all this continuous stuff
well you can't do it if you need a whole
pile of hardware
that's really difficult really expensive
and you can go into it move in for two
days then move out again you can't just
sort of rerun them every time you commit
your program so
it is actually difficult to test and uh
the technologies in distributed systems
are not easy to understand
um i i'll give you some examples of that
um i'll just frighten you off a little
bit but they are kind of kind of tricky
so i can look at data so
highly available data i'm going to say
data is sacred and computation isn't
you really need to look after your data
make sure you never lose it
the computation that's just stuff that
transforms data so
if if a program crashes just rerun it or
something like that
that's not a problem you can perform the
computation anywhere provided you can
get hold of the data
i'm going to look just at a sub problem
and that's how to make
highly available data um
because okay so let's look at the where
is my data problem i i like this so
i'm actually got 10 million that's my
thing you've got 10 million
computers and you've put your data joe's
data is on
three or four of them so the first
question you want to ask is
well in order to access my data i need
to know which computer i've put my data
on uh how could i find that out
right oh that's pretty easy we know how
to do that
um so most of the algorithms this is one
of my favorite out of the chord
algorithm uh that that
tells you how to put data how to find
the computer that all my data's on if
i've got millions of computers so for
those of you who don't know it i'll just
go through it rapidly
what you do is you map the
ip addresses or the hash of the ip
addresses and the hash of the keys
into the same name space okay so give
you a simple example of this and use md5
as the hashing function so suppose
you've got three machines oh
more than three i've got several
machines there but the first three
machines have got ip addresses 235 23 34
12 and so on so the first thing i can do
is compute a hash
sorry an md5 checksum of those and and i
did that there
and then sort those md5 check sums
okay so the next list here that's the
sorted md5 checksums and then if i've
got
a particular data suppose suppose i got
a key
something like this male number two so
if i hash that into an md5 checks i will
also get
an md5 checksum if you compare that with
the this list here
okay and you say well that occurs in the
third position in this list here and the
third
position well between the second you see
the the first two entries the hash of
oh nine nine three four that's machine
s2 because i've sorted them
and the second hash is machine s3 and so
on so this hash here
occurs between the second and third
entries in that row and that says it's
just a conventional i'll store that data
on the machine with the hash that's the
first value that's lower than that
okay so i'm going to store that on the
machine s3
okay so by hashing
key values into the same namespace as
the hash of the ip addresses we can
figure out which of these machines to
store it
on and you want a replica
well you hash it again so you get two
machines um and store the second one on
the second sheet because it might hash
to the same machine so
it went to the same machine just do it
again and that's the chord algorithm
right and it's actually the basis of all
on the all distributed hash tables and
most of them work like that so it's
actually quite easy to understand
very pretty algorithm okay so let's look
at these replicas
so if they can find the data that's not
a problem that's pretty easy
but i'm trying to replicate data in case
the machine's crashing so we'll store in
two or more places now life
becomes a bit more difficult so so your
first thing is okay
the first thought that people have about
replicas is um i know what we'll do
we'll keep an odd number of copies and
we'll vote
you know you'll send out like say keep
five copies and you
send them out and and when three of the
machines have said yeah yeah we agree
then you say yeah it's okay what about
the two that didn't agree i'll forget
about them for a moment
um uh this uh we'll forget about them
for the moment is gonna come and bite us
in the
bottom i think uh later
but never mind it sort of looks okay the
majority wins and what about the time
oh oh that's brilliant look at that
we've got some master machine here
and uh it's broadcast to five machines
and then it gets five answers but all
this takes place in parallel
okay so in wave one you send out five
messages
and then you get five replies um
that's great fantastic as soon as you've
got more than three replies you can say
yeah that's great
so you can have 17 replicas or you could
have 9999 replicas
and wait until more than half of them
are applied and and you're okay
which isn't that easy you see it's
linear time don't do it doesn't matter
how many replicas
easy to find the machine everything's
simple yeah
now at this point you're thinking ah
distributed data is really easy right
right so making replicas is pretty easy
isn't it right so if we can make
9 999 replicas world's going to be easy
so
i just thought let's look at two i'm
a bit sort of you know i like to
understand things so
so so i think well i don't really
understand 999 right
let's try and understand what's involved
in making two
replicas because that's a much easier
problem
right so so here's here's some here's
how
here's how we got two replicas you see
let's suppose we've got a master machine
a and a replica machine b
and we we send a message to it set x is
10
sends a message to the b machine set x
is 10 and you get an ack
from the b machine you get an act from
the a machine so so at this stage
what we know about the system is
asymmetric
right because a knows that x is replica
is replicated on b but b
does not know that x is replicated on a
because somebody might have told b a to
change the value
and it hasn't yet got a signal right
so it's asymmetric and that's going to
be very nasty
right so so let's see so what happens if
everything
let's suppose we've got a well it's not
going to kind of work like that because
you've got two machines a and b
and you've got a client they can't talk
to a all the time because they don't
know where a is
so normally you have a sort of load
balancer or a master machine that knows
where a and b
is and so the client actually talks to
the master machine who knows where a
and b are and it always talks to a so
this is what happens if everything works
so the the user sends a message to the
manager
that knows where a is that that's the
manager is a program that's executing
the chord algorithm
okay so it sends a message to aceta and
you get all these acts back and it all
works beautifully
and there we go so we've set x equal to
10 and then we set it equal to 20 and
everything's fine right
so hang on what happens if a crashes
and then the client asks for the value
of x
well up to this oh sorry so it's crashed
at this point so
the user set x equal to 10 and some
stuff's worked here and that's fine then
he said x equal to 20
and some stuff's worked and then this
process crashes at this point
here so the master here knows that a has
crashed
and now somebody asks for x
okay hmm well the master knows that a is
crashed so he asks b
and he gets back a value of b that's 10.
so what can you reply oh dear this isn't
a sort of unsafe value of x i know it's
10 but it might not be
right because you see it actually i mean
it's been 20 here
but he can't he can't ask a because i is
dead
but he knows that eve died and he knows
that the so oh dear so we've got this um
unsafe value of x now what do you want
in your program well you do a get and
put into a database and you say yeah
what's the value of x yes 10 what's the
value of x 10
oops what's the value x well i think it
might be 10.
so so programmers don't want to know
this
[Music]
and so other programmers put
abstractions like two-faced commit so
even though you're getting it well i'm
unsure about this really they say oh i'm
sure i'm sure it's ten
you know right
so now we have to what happens if the
master now
well wait a minute look hang on so this
was kind of tricky you see here's the
a has died but the master process hasn't
died it's still living
and then it's beginning to get a tiny
bit complicated now
so now we said oh what happens if the
master process itself
dies right this is you don't want to
know
stuff well i'm going to tell you a
little bit right
life gets a tad tricky okay so have any
of you heard of the paxos algorithm
right so you know life is a tad tricky
because of the pa
so the paxos algorithm is distributed
leadership election
it's the problem you have a leader just
dies and then you've got to
in a distributed way um figure out who a
new leader is and you kind of vote and
take the majority but
as you're voting you might lose messages
and they might die
so if you look it up say on wikipedia or
something you'll find these signal
diagrams they look they look pretty much
like the ones i've been drawing
only there's about 15 to 20 of them that
look like that
but that's one of the simpler ones that
will fit on the slide
so in in making this lecture i
did a a little bit of research and i i
found i found a quote i rather like
because it was from a paper
um the paper was called in search of an
understandable consensus algorithm
i like the word sort of understandable
consensus algorithm and and
to read a bit it says unfortunately
paxis has two significant drawbacks the
first drawback is that paxus
is exceptionally difficult to understand
the full explanation is notoriously
opaque few people will succeed in
understanding it and only with great
effort
as a result there have been several
attempts to explain it these
explanations focus on a single degree
taxes they are still challenging leave
them leave the reader with not enough
information to build a
practical system in an informal survey
of attendees at
something over we found few people are
comfortable with practice even among
seasoned researchers
we struggled with packs ourselves we
were not able to understand the original
paper that's the one pax has simply
explained you know so
um uh until several
simplified explanations in designing our
own alternative protocols
and look who wrote it well one of the
authors is john us to have
do you remember tcl
very nice and so john us i mean he's not
a dumb guy right he designs programming
languages and programming language
designers um
sort of a bit anal about understanding
stuff so try and figure out how it works
so
so if john us says he couldn't
understand it and it's kind of tricky
stuff that's that's good enough for me
you know i mean it is actually so
that's the bad news okay
so what's the good news well
the good news is that it's been solved
in the airline i'm going to say quotes
in the airing libraries you see
so so um so there's a gen leader thing
in um in the yelling libraries
that itself is a sort of that was
this problem was so difficult that um
we had a research project to do this
and the research bit of it was to i mean
the project
was to write the leadership election
algorithm and the research bit was to
prove that it was correct
right and they proved it was correct and
it ran for several years and then
i can't remember when it first was but
then they got a bug report
that the leadership election was
actually electing two different leaders
and it was reproducible
and this was a bit of a problem because
it actually proved to be correct so
so it went back to the people who proved
it and they said oh well we had to make
a few simplifying assumptions in order
to do the proof
so um
it's believed to be correct at the
moment
and if you don't want our libraries
there are things like react
um which is a database which implement
these kind of algorithms and they
actually if you find react actually is
quite nice because instead of um
sending this normally things
hide the voting structure so if you've
got
five replicas and
you really wanted to be sure that it
really worked you'd really like to maybe
know that you've got five commits
not three most databases don't allow you
to do this react
has this kind of layer of fine control
where you can sort of say well i really
do actually want to know exactly what's
going on and you could
sort of go in at different levels which
is very nice
so this was just a little sort of
introduction to some of the problems you
get in in distributed programming
um i don't think
that you need a lot of complicated fancy
algorithms to do distributed programming
but certain ones like replicating data
you do need
and you certainly don't want to
implement them with yourself so you
really want kind of rock
solid industrial quality implementation
for that stuff and don't try and build
it yourself
unless you're a research group and want
to spend 10 years doing it before you
you know if you just want to build
something
take these libraries and use them you
don't actually need that many there's
libraries like react
um amqp the rabbit mq is a persistent
message queue
think about it you can implement a heck
of a lot of things just using persistent
message queues and it's just nice to
know
that somebody else has done all that
work of putting that into the library
these are the libraries you want
you don't need libraries for web
services
any fool can write them right but this
stuff is difficult
okay right so let's let let's
let's look at some rules for the these
are these are sort of properties
that you need if you want to make fault
tolerant systems and
you know when people
i don't like you know slides with well
i've got slightest bullets but you know
trouble with slides with bullets is all
the bullet points are the same size so
you don't know which is most important
um so really i'd like a patent you know
big bullets mean it's important small
books mean it's not important so
if you put on a bulleted list all the
things that are important
the the the biggest bullet of all is
isolation
processes must all computations must be
isolated from each other that means that
one process can't crash another one it
doesn't really matter if my process
is i mean suppose i've proved my process
correct and tested it and
it's wonderful and then some other
bloody idiot comes along just crashes it
you know pulls pulls the plug out
you know i've proved your program to be
correct i've built a fault tolerance
system you know you've built it on one
computer and some guy comes and i say oh
yeah and pulls out the plug
it's not a fault tolerant is it you know
so this isolation property
is very important i i know because this
computer is isolated
i know that if i just walk into the can
can i walk into the audience do i have a
volunteer
who will give me one of these beautiful
computers i'll smash it
and show that my slides are still
working do we have a volunteer
or do you believe me
sir can i take your computer to smash it
do i do i need to smash your computer or
do you believe me you believe me right
that's great
take the challenge you know sort of you
know i'd be really surprised if i went
and smashed a computer here
and the slideshow stopped or if somebody
smashed a computer in sweden
and it's stopped that's isolation okay
and we want that for our software right
so what does once you've got isolation
what does it give you what do you get
for isolation you get a heck of a lot of
nice things you get
you get fault tolerance because
you know if i if i just smash this
machine it's not going to cause what's
going on in these other machines to to
to
to stop it gives you scalability because
if i have
organized my computation so that it will
run on one machine
isolated from another then if i want
twice the power or ten times the power
just get ten computers and
put ten of these things so designing my
system
for isolation making sure the bits are
isolated
gives me scalability and it gives me
reliability okay pretty much the same
assault it also gives me testability
because i've isolated it
i can test it in isolation if it's not
isolated if it's lots of bits all glued
together how the heck you test it
the more i can isolate the bits the
better i can test them
it gives me comprehensibility because
this act of isolation is
taking things into smaller components
talking to them through protocols that
gives me the ability to test them
okay and it gives me the ability to
upgrade the code in them
because once i've isolated all of these
i can now go around the room turning on
off turning off one at a time changing
the code and putting it back online
again then going to the next one
so i'm going to get all these things for
free
provided i have made an architecture
with isolated components okay
so once they are isolated the next
property i need is concurrency
can i describe a computation in terms of
concurrent processes because
if i've now isolated them they are
concurrent i can't do anything about
that so it's a kind of it's
does my system i'm not talking about
programming is it an operating system a
programming language does it
enable the description of concurrency
in a sort of rather natural sort of way
okay um
well why do i want concurrency well um
world just happens to be concurrently
parallel you know just
go out on the street if you don't
believe it's concurrent just walk over
the street outside there you know when
all the cars have
whizzing by you know tis all these cars
are sort of zooming around
all this stuff is happening if you try
and describe that in a sequential
process
yes how would you do it i don't know how
you can't so i mean the world actually
is concurrent so let's try and describe
it in
a concurrent language um or a concurrent
way that doesn't mean to say it will
execute in parallel
it means the description is as of a set
of parallel
the concurrent activities you see i
can't if if i run it on a sequential
processor
one core computer it'll never be
parallel it will be concurrent however
i get the illusion of parallelism by
interleaving the cpu if i've got like a
thousand computers i've got a 10
core cpu i can run 10 parallel
processors on it i can't run 11.
i can run a million concurrent
processors only into leaving on to the
10
processor we have to distinguish these
two two ideas
um we also need you know at least two
computers to um
to make a non-stop system i always
thought that was obvious
until um you see i've been working for
this
so long i didn't realize that people
thought oh you actually you know you can
make a fault tolerance system on one
machine i said what happens if you smash
the whole machine
oh i didn't think of that so um
so erickson you see we we um
we we do this sort of mike mike williams
who worked with him a few years and
co-developer like
he said he was erickson built military
systems and they were
they had a bit that built build things
for
generals and people with funny hats on
and
um and uh so this general came in and
said
you've got to talk about you know two
machines you're not one out it carries
on on the other one and um
and and and he was very pleased about
this because he said to my
always wonder what will happen with a
new kit one of the exchanges so you're
telling me if a new kit
won't exchange it will still carry on
going well sort of
my mental model of this was like two
computers sort of
in the same building it stood up with a
wire in between and duplicated power
supplies so
you wouldn't have sort of mental models
of being like 400 kilometers between
them to
guard from nuclear weapons and things
but a little bit of thought said yes it
would work
so general was happy uh
yeah so you know concurrency it kind of
goes together with this distribution
well i mean if it's distributed it is
concurrent you've got to live with it
you can't
so so here's a funny thing you see if
you want to write fault tolerant
software
you have to do concurrent and
distributed programming whether you like
it or not
it's not an alternative not to
understand distributed programming if
you want to build fault tolerance
systems
because you do need two computers they
are in parallel they are distributed you
can't get away from that
right next thing you want to do is
detect failures
machines are going to die
so if you can't detect the fact that
they've died
you won't be able to correct any errors
that occur when they die
pretty obvious
failure detection right so yeah if you
can't detect failure you can't fix it
and this has to work not it's got to
work sort of transparently across
machine boundaries
um and that implies
uh actually non sort of
non-shared data structures you've got a
cop
you can't have like dangling pointers
over machine boundaries
you can't sort of lazily transfer data
and have half the data on one machine
and half the data on another machine
because if one of the machines crashes
you've lost half your data
because it sort of implies this kind of
pure message passing where you copy
everything
the the real reason for that is fault
tolerance it's not to do with anything
else it's not to do with efficiency or
anything
i mean i also you know first of all you
make systems right
that means fault tolerance and then you
make them fast you see so consequence of
making them right is you can't have
lazy data structures with dangling
pointers over machines you have to copy
everything otherwise you can't make it
fault torrent
and actually i also want it to be
asynchronous message passing because you
can't do
synchronous message when the world is
asynchronous light
sort of moves from a to b and takes a
certain amount of time and you
can't change the laws of physics right
uh we build fault tolerant things into
into
little in airline we we build them into
trees of things that sort of watch each
other
and these work transparently over
machine boundaries and this is a kind of
logical picture
they could all be processes on the same
machine
or they could be processed on different
machines it doesn't really matter
you need also fault identification it's
not enough to know
that something's crashed you really want
to know why it's crashed um
at the lowest level ellen gives you a
kind of simple uh
yeah it crashed because you divided by
zero or it crashed because
something was wrong uh but you can tune
that you could
you could send a lot of entire databases
with you when it cracks you send the
entire state of the system when it
crashes if you want to
yeah and
yeah i said that and then you want live
code upgrade
pretty obvious won't really say much
about that
uh i did say something about it you want
zero downtime
once you've started you know no there's
no stop button on your software you
press the start button that's it go home
go forever um and you want stable
storage i mentioned stable that's this
you know store my data um that's one of
the tricky things to do that that's you
can't that's not a property of
programming now it's a property of
programming language and algorithms and
operating systems and all sorts of stuff
but it's kind of pretty good now uh you
can this is kind of off the shelf stuff
uh you know it's quite nice if you've
got proper storage you don't need backup
anymore
what the hell got backup for you don't
need backup
backups something you want in case your
machine crashes but if you've
never crashes you don't need backup do
you so you remove that you do need
snapshots you know because you overwrite
your data but you don't need backups
uh you you need crash reports and things
like that when it crashes it's nice
it's nice if you can come back later and
say oh well despite it's all crashed
it's still in the storage why it crashed
when we started
um i just wrote a quick
few quotes from various people about
harry potter systems and things like
that well
um jim gray that's actually the
paper why computer stop and what can be
done about it um
do anybody of you remember the tandem
computer
oh excellent good not the only one with
gray hairs
um eric is in one sense
the tandem computer in software it's
architecture it's very much like the
tanner because
um i read jupiter's report and i mailed
him and said uh
you know ellen he he'd he postulated if
you do all this in software it worked
pretty much like the hardware he said
and i said yeah well we've done it in
software it doesn't work pretty much
like the hardware and he mailed back and
said yeah i know
it would do he also said welcome to the
church of concurrency he said in his
mail which i
thought was rather nice and he said in
order
to i just highlighted a bit see process
achieves fault containment by sharing no
state uh with other processes only
contact with other processes via
messages carried by the kernel messaging
system so that was the only way that
uh data could be exchanging in tandem
and uh he said the key to software fault
tolerance is to hierarchically decompose
large systems to model each module being
a unit of service and a unit of failure
and the failure of the module should not
propagate beyond the module this seems
to me
straightforward actually um i haven't
got it on this slide but postel's law of
um
making matters worse law you know sort
of be be tolerant in what you accept and
you know this is absolute nightmare
because
you know you send what are you supposed
to do you define a protocol and then you
send a message that is
in violation of the protocol and you say
oh well that's okay we'll let it in
anyway you know
it's horrible you shouldn't do that you
could
crash immediately no and then and then
gray
a guy called great oh well it's pretty
much the same
transaction mechanism and process per
software modularity through processing
that's the same
same sort of idea and uh
there's a notion of fail fast um
the process approach to fault isolation
advocates that process software should
be fail fast that either a function
should
function correctly or should detect the
fault and stop operating
as soon as you've got a fault you stop
don't make matters worse by continuing
right and then fail early
this is uh this is somebody else uh
a fault in a software system can cause
one or more errors the latency
time is the interval between the
existence of the fault and the
occurrence of error can be very high
which complicates the backward analysis
of the error
uh this is a paper from uh sort of
business systems if you
if error occurs now and you carry on and
carry on and carry on and carry on and
then
you get the symptom it's very difficult
going backwards to find out where it
occurred
right and here we go oh alan kaye
uh this is a nice melee center a
reminder
uh that it took some pains at the last
opportunity to extend this small
talk it's not only about its syntax and
class libraries it's not even about
classes i'm sorry
that i a long time ago coined the term
object
for this topic because it gets many
people to focus on the lesser idea
the big idea is messaging so the big
idea of object-oriented programming is
messaging it's not
objects and it's not classes
and it's not methods it's not how
they're organized that's abstract data
types
the big idea in object building program
is messaging and poly
poly uh let's say polyphonic polymorphic
messaging
right and of course all this is in
erlang
uh and schneider uh oh it's just it's
the same sort of stuff
anyway i summed all this up into joe's
quote let it crash
right so just just let your software
crash now crashing
is a big deal in sequential programming
languages
because you've only got one process
so if you crash you're screwed right
well what else do you do okay so wait a
minute the corollary to this all
sequential programming languages get
error handling wrong
every single one it doesn't matter what
they are doesn't matter if they're java
haskell small talk
all of them they're all wrong because
they all
have this notion of one sequential
computation you've got to do everything
inside it so you have to keep it
alive no matter what happens
so what happens when you're writing a
program and you get to the point in the
program
where you cannot return a value to
something
where it doesn't make any sense to
continue because you figured out
that what what's going wrong didn't
agree with what should be you've got a
violation of your internal logic
what can you do you have no alternative
but to crash
you can't logically continue there is no
way you can
suppose you suppose you've got a
factorial you know suppose you've got a
divide
divide by x and x turns out to be zero
what do you do you can't continue in it
you can't i mean throw not a number or
something come on you know just crash
goodness sake you see it's not a problem
with this airline because you've got
millions of processors all watching it
who cares if a few processes crashed
right right so so there were six rules
so how are we going to program them well
what's erlang
um going to program you know
uh so that length is a functional
program what kind of three things um
which it's like this will come you know
when you unwrap the parcel you find
three things inside it it's it's a
a functional programming language um
probably in respect to haskell it
shouldn't actually
be a big f it will be little little f
it's got a few non-functional things in
for
pragmatic reasons um you can program in
a very functional way if you want to
you can also don't have to
uh it's a set of design principles they
they go under the name of otp
it's a very self-evident name middleware
open telecoms platform oh well we're not
doing telecoms it's useless right so
um but it's all about that's all about
fault tolerance and
setting up these things and it's a
virtual machine called the beam
b stands for well it was designed by
bogdan houseman
this is what it's a b in it so it's bob
bogdan's abstract machine but then
bogdan left and burn took over so
so bjorn gustafson now now supports it
and so it's
bogdan and bjorn's airline abstract
machine
um and
right so how do we program the fixture
well use libraries or
we could use things in airline that were
designed to do that okay so
uh what about the ice okay let's go
through the
the isolation rule well airing processes
just are isolated uh one process cannot
damage another by accident it can
you can damn it it could damage it
deliberately extend an exit signal to it
but that's not accidental
you shouldn't be perhaps you can't
accidentally damage other things
and also you can't really kill it it
might set a flag saying no you're not
allowed to kill me
um but there is a special message that
you can actually kill process even if
they've said you're not allowed to kill
them
and an airline node can can have
millions of processes um
they take about 300 bytes per process
you get three
uh three processes per kilobyte
to get three thousand processors per
megabyte and three million processors
per gigabyte
um but that's before they've
doing anything so you know with a few
gigabytes of memory you can you can run
up
you know a few tens of millions of
processes without any problems just
try it at home it's quite easy they've
got no shared memory
and they're very lightweight they're
much lighter weight than threads i mean
operating system threads are very very
very heavy compared to
to to align presses and threads are evil
anyway because so they share resources
so
you know my treads don't obey this i
mean here's the crazy thing you've got
nice things in operating systems which
are actually
isolated so one process can't [ __ ] up in
other processes internal data structures
but threads are evil
because what's the difference between a
thread and a process are the threads can
[ __ ] up each other's internal data
structures
so they're absolutely the things you
don't want to program with
right uh concurrency well airline
processors are concurrent yeah they all
run in
parallel in theory and
uh actually on a multicore they really
do run in parallel
uh but you can't get more parallelism
out than the number of cores so you've
got a four core machine
you're not actually running more than
four of these
process at a time and they're scheduled
and they're preemptively scheduled
and they they um they they do
within a thread they block for i o but
they're non-blocking with respect to
other processes so
so um uh the process will go like read
write read
go read write read write read write read
and when it's when it says read
it waits but it doesn't affect anybody
else
so they all can carry on so it's not one
of these funny languages that say
uh issue a read request on read complete
call this function over there somewhere
bye and then and then the read complete
goes it goes right right right read on
read complete go over there and do
something
you know it's not like that so it's
actually easy to understand
and it's actually just three little
things in early
you know spawn creates a parallel
process pit bank message sends a message
and receive the pattern
um oriented uh syntax
what it actually does it doesn't
actually send a message to the process
each process has a mailbox okay so you
send to the mailbox
so this this this this is just like
regular mailboxes
pid bank message tells
the vm which is a postman says deliver
this message to this guy so it doesn't
need to know where it is this is
location transparent
this will find its way over the network
it's just like a letter if i
if i put naca garten27 on a thing and
pop it in the post it'll turn up in my
mailbox
in sweden okay so that's the same as in
erlang you once you know this address
bit bang message just to send it off and
it'll end up in the mailbox
and this receive operation says hey just
go look in the mailbox and see if you've
got any of these mails
it just takes them out any other mails
that are there won't lift them out so
there's a patent
matching operation that lifts things out
of the mailbox
right that's the concurrency bit the
failure detection bit
just says well you can set up a link
between these processes
um if the process dies it'll send you a
message and it'll end up in your mailbox
that's all it says actually two types of
messages um
actually the technical signals um what
really happens is
if you don't do anything and you link to
another process and it dies and if the
reason it dies is because of an error
not a normal death you you yourself die
and you
send out messages to to to the process
you're linked to and the reason for that
is there's a there's a classic problem
in distributed programming and that's of
you can set up lots of parallel
processes
that collaborate to do something but
what happens if any one of them goes
wrong
at that stage you want to make sure that
everything dies that's involved every
single process you might have 15
processes all sort of spread out doing
stuff
and if you want the invariant if anyone
dies we all die
so that's what the link does just set
the links up it doesn't matter who
starts they'll all die
and it's an invariant um
that's why we don't do defensive
programming actually we
you know file system on unix you the
process opens a file
and starts reading and writing to it if
it crashes
the operating system closes the file in
a nice sort of way so that
so the next program that comes along can
open that file it's not like the file is
broken forever because the process that
was using it crashed
so real time things we grew we we all we
do is we sort of assume they're going to
work
program them as if they're going to work
and then set up some guys who monitor
them and if they fail
we put back these invariants just kind
of pick up the pieces and put them back
together again
let's see failure detection uh
and yeah
we pretty religious about fixing errors
remotely
um you can't fix your own errors
okay so if i if i fell over and had a
heart attack
and you know need open-heart surgery i'm
not gonna do it myself
you know like where's the knife you know
some medics come in and sort of carry
you know some other guy fixes me up when
i'm
you know dying and things like that so
we do that with processes think of
these errors they're like little
ambulances that sort of run in and fix
up
things that go wrong it gives you very
nice separation of issues you've got
processes whose only job is to do stuff
and you've got other processes only job
is to repair
what's gone wrong if the process that do
stuff fail and then you've got managers
if their only job is to manage
people and start and stop them and and
do things
so it makes makes it actually pretty
pretty nice
and uh yeah here's
one or two little extra things that we
bunged in here spawn link that that
spawn created a process
spawn link creates a process with a link
so that if the process dies
you get a message if you don't do that
statement there your process will die
if the other process dies but if you do
put that statement in uh you get a
error message which you can receive just
like anything else
and we've got some live code upgrade
uh this actually it's it's quite
convenient
to that this actually means something
different if you call if you call bar
and you've got a module with bar in here
and the mod is called foo
it'll always call that no matter what
happens but if you say food colombar
and you upgrade the code for bar at the
same time as you're running it
then this will hop into the new version
of the module and carry on in the new
version and the old one will carry on in
the old version
so actually you can have you can now
without changing the names of any of
your modules
uh you can actually have two completely
logically different versions running at
the same time they've all got the same
names
and and this this old version is
well actually it's a mistake in the
language um
when airline was designed we didn't have
much memory
uh i mean that was 86 something like
that
today i would do it different today i
would have multiple versions with the
same namespace and garbage collect
code you know if you're if you're
performing a computation
i mean suppose we spawn 500 processes to
do the same thing
and some of them are long-lived some of
them might last for months others are
short-lived and then and then we go
again in a second do it again
we might change the code while we're
doing it um we don't really want to
change the code in the
things at all every point in time you
maybe want them to run to completion
even though the code is old until we get
to the
next time they restart and then give
them new code the next time they start
but we don't want to kill off the old
ones using the old code just because
we've changed a new code
so it's like having regular modules or
classes or namespaces but thinking you
can actually run the old code and the
new code at the same time
so imagine java you've got a class
called something or other and it's in
the jvm and you change
all the definitions and just bung it in
again and bung it in again and banging
it but the old ones that are still
running elker they're still running the
old
the new ones are running the new code
and it's all hunky dorian works fine
and then we've got stuff for stable
storage um
manesia is a real-time database
that has the property that you can
configure it for multiple nodes and it
replicates in ram and and does things
like that
it's all very nice i'm running out of
time
oh let's see
so once you've done all this once you're
thinking in terms of isolation the
isolation thing forces you when you
design your system to break it up into
separated components so it's kind of
rather nice you see
in order to make things fault tolerant
you have to design it so that the
components are isolated
and so you've got your scalability for
free you didn't have to think about how
to scale it because you've designed it
correctly
hey that's great it comes for free but
it's the other way around suppose
another guy is going along so i want to
make a scalable system so you design it
in isolated components
it's become fault tolerant for free
well hang on wait a minute if they're
isolated and it's scalable
maybe we can run it on a multi-core
yeah and then it should go faster yeah
so when the multi-cores get this is
probably why air language took off back
2004 the multi-core started coming along
we ran a lot of programs on multi-cores
they just went faster we didn't have to
do anything to them at all just bung
them on the multi-cores they went faster
um so the goal was you know sort of
you know if you go to quad core take
your old program bung it on the quad
core should go four times faster we hope
some programs do
actually our goal is to get like 75
of the number of cpus in speed up so if
you've got 12 cores we hope to get
like eight a factor eight speed up
without doing anything
of course it depends how you've written
your programs if you've written them
with one big
process you get no game but if you've
written them with lots of little
processes
you should get these gains it's very
unusual that you don't get any gain at
all and then
as you start scaling up funny things can
happen i'm going to show you a little
bit about that
in a while uh so actually it's it's kind
of
it's kind of fun because everybody else
is saying uh
how do we take a sequential program
and run it and parallelize it so we can
run it on a multi-core and the airline
people are saying
well it already runs on a multi-core how
do we find bottlenecks
so look we're looking for bottlenecks
now we're not we've already figured out
how to
when you write your program every time
you write spawn in your program you're
saying oh i've decided
that can be done in a parallel process
and then you just bang it on a
multi-core goes faster um
we're looking for the bottlenecks now
and i'll show you that because that's
quite fun
uh so what do we got when all of this
we've got this is the kind of summary
we've got lightweight processes fast
message passing total separation between
pros
stuff very nice stuff actually more of
this is kind of
what you would associate with operating
systems rather than you see airline's
not really
you don't need an operating system
really the operating system just sort of
when airline starts it just says to the
operators give me a heck of a lot of
memory please
and that's about the only monitor call
it makes and then it does everything
itself i mean it schedules itself and it
doesn't use the operating system shared
or anything like that that's awfully big
the stuff let's have a look uh and we've
got all this stuff
um i'm gonna hop over a bit of this it's
taking too long
uh yeah i've run on to a few little
projects just to show
um it's not just erickson that uses
erlang um
couchdb was one of the first projects
that
kind of spread a little bit and quite a
lot of people use and then react
um there's some react people here so go
and ask them about react
i'll tell you how wonderful it is chef
11
in case you don't know this is um this
is the thing that
it's a it's a management system that
monitors
machines so i think the chef 11 servers
are written in airling now
um it's client server architect servers
written in airline clients are written
in ruby
and you monitor loads of machines so one
airline node that can monitor about
i don't know 100 000 machines or
something like that so that's being
rolled into facebook so airling is
will be controlling every single
facebook node on the planet
um it's quite nice because it's sort of
it's good for that kind of thing it's
good for monitoring thousands of
machines good for
having you know you can get about three
five million sockets running on one
reasonably sized machine in airline
uh moki web uh that was running
facebook chat with um run using that for
a while uh
it's not using it anymore um it's been
replaced by it by
i think a web server called cowboy you
know scolaris was a
distributed peer-to-peer thing actually
they implemented the wikipedia not the
real wikipedia the research group in
germany won the prize for the best
scalable system
they they implemented the entire
wikipedia using something like one-tenth
of the number of machines that the wiki
really really uses but it was written
but they never managed to sell it into
wiki i think uh
this um this is quite interesting
egyptian it's it's an xmpp server it's
the
most widely used xmpp server in the
world
and it was actually that code that was
modified to form makiweb
and a lot of things and it's actually um
whatsapp
you know the whatsapp application this
is a mobile thing
which switches i think they were saying
10 billion messages a day or something
that was actually based on the xmpp code
by a student who'd learnt airline and
they built this thing i think
value to i reckon they'll sell
themselves to google or facebook for a
few billion dollars so i mean that's
what you can do if you just learn a
language student
just just write i mean nobody's
interested in commercial
uh you know in sort of programming name
but they you make money by building
applications that people want to use
uh rabbit mq this is
the first compliant
implementation of the advanced message
queue protocol rabbitmq did this and
then they were required
by by uh well i can't remember the name
of the company it was then acquired by
um vmware so the vmware distributed
systems actually using airline sort of
hidden in the bottom
layer using rabbitmq to to manage them
it's quite fun uh
and uh yeah uh a lot of companies
erickson's
pretty big and ellen using a lot basho
of tlf uh
clarner this is these are all swedish
companies you probably don't know much
about them but i mean
at the current rate of expansion this is
going to be bigger than google in about
six years time
it's a financial company and it's grown
it's the first
pure airline company that's valued over
a billion dollars and it's got
like 800 employees or something from in
five years and it's going
crazily good um and whatsapp is
tailf is managing a lot of cisco routers
and things
you know there's um a load of books uh
this is a one this is actually a really
good write um
i don't know if it's a good read but it
was it was quite fun writing it the
second edition of the airline book so
it's got all the new things in airline
that none of the other books have got in
yet
right so so a couple of slides on some
fun stuff um
what what's in the future i'm going to
show you two slides um
well i think this is kind of alexia
is really fun it's like a
son of airline or daughter of erlang
it's a language that uses
the same you know i said earlier three
things a language it's a set of
libraries
and it's a virtual machine so alexia is
the same virtual machine it runs on top
of the airline virtual machine so all
these nice things i talked about all
these things about links
all these things about process isolation
all of that
is in the alloying virtual machine it's
not anything in airling itself it's in
the virtual machine so
alexa gets all that stuff
and it's got a ruby-like syntax
and it's got some fancy meta programming
in that you can't do in airline so it's
actually very nice
very it's really cool and
it's taking place in a completely
different way
than early so when airline was developed
that was before the world wide web that
we were
talking about this in 1985 1986 robert
heading and i and
mike and we i mean the the number of
people who could take
part in this debate about how a
programming language should be
was limited to to the number of people
in the coffee room you know we talked
about it every day
oh i should do it this way no i don't
know but this debate is taking place on
the net so i'm
you know there's a mailing list there
i'm talking to yourself alien and
mailing him and say why do you do this
and a lot of people are contributing
ideas people who've never met you know
people in the soviet union people in
america
and it's airing i think the gap between
the first
book and erlang was somewhat like 14
years
right the gap here is about a year
because dave thomas is
uh who's the guy who introduced ruby to
everybody he's written this programming
alexia
and the first drafts out of the beta
book you can buy it and read it now
and uh there's an o'reilly book that's
out i've read both the drafts
and um so the the documentation the
books which you need
are being co-developed with the language
we've never seen this before
it's always been this long gap even ruby
ruby was kind of developed and then dave
wrote the books
so i think this synergy effect is going
to be very good
and i think it's a very exciting
experiment because
the otp people are really keen on this
and i'm very keen on it because
we can combine kind of youthful
enthusiasm with sort of this old style
engineering practice we know we know
there's a lot of engineering there's
probably
hundreds and hundreds of manuals of work
in the virtual machine and in the
libraries and we can just sort of
glue them all together so this is very
exciting uh
the other stuff this this is cool i'm
just going to show you a little video
uh if i can make it work
this is concurrence now somebody earlier
asked about wait a minute i've got to go
to
somebody asked about um
could you somebody said you know can you
find bottlenecks and things like that
so let's remember that picture i showed
with lots of little dots
that say how do we understand the system
like this well
let's see if this works oh where's my
thing to press
oh heck oh there
let's hope this works
what
shouldn't be so violent there any sound
please
no thank you joe and hello lambda jam
my name is alex canaris and i'm the ceo
of concurrence corporation
today i'd like to show you a few of the
tools we've been working on
for erlang performance
our flagship product is a real-time
visual profiler
it consists of two parts a tracer which
hooks into the erlang virtual machine
and a set of html5 visualizations
installation is easy simply add it to
your rebar config and away you go
the code here is for a website that
generates mandarin sets
it's a simple program written in the
excellent chicago boss framework
now let's see this in action here it is
running live
in the concurrence visualization tools
every circle represents an erlang
process the size of the circle is
proportional to the amount of
computation
lines represent communication patterns
and the yellow dots represent
the actual messages being sent so far
it's pretty stable not much happening
let's add some load to it and see what
happens as we're adding load you can see
hot spots develop as the program
struggles to keep
up the beauty of these visualizations is
that it makes it super easy to see
exactly where your program is has a
bottlenecks here we're zooming in
on the bottleneck in this particular
program
bottleneck that we found is a common one
in erlang where many worker processes
communicate with a central singleton
process and that singleton process
becomes a chokepoint for scalability
to figure out what it is simply put your
mouse over it
and you'll be told the module name
function and process id of the offending
bottleneck
well that's it for our whirlwind demo of
a real-time visual profiler we hope you
found it interesting and useful and look
forward to your feedback
thank you all very much
so that's
what you can see when you know it's like
a gas i'm wondering if it's going to
obey boltzmann's equations or something
or um boyle's law pv is rt you know if
you
if you compress this you know the
processes get hotter and they sort of
buzz around faster and
the cpu will get warmer and i i want to
see if
if we get to like statistical mechanics
for understanding how these work
because i think we need to go from this
yeah i'll show you this picture we need
to go from this world where we think
that
we program using single processes to
this world where we
program with sort of thousands and
thousands or millions of processes that
are communicating with each other so
i think if you take away a message from
from from this talk is
i think that's what we need to be
thinking about it's not how single
processes behave
it's how aggregates of millions of
processes behave
and how to build systems out of that so
i think that's
about where i get to yeah thank you